في نجاح ما عاد غريب عليها ما يكساب
مكتسحه الترند ومتالقه في العمده وبين
العمده والصندوق احمد داش نجم عملين هذا
الرمضان وفي دور عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن
اليماني بطل في سفر بربك وكلام الشافعي
يشعل الجدل والانتقادات لمسلسل رساله
الامام اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الفنانه مي كساب من الاسماء الفنيه
الاساسيه في السباق الرمضاني اخر كم سنه
وحقيقه سنه عن سنه بتورينا اداء اروع من
اللي قبله هذه السنه مي متالقه في مسلسل
جعفر العمده الى جانب محمد رمضان وهاله
صدقي وغيرهم دور الزوجه الاولى لجعفر
العمده اللي هو محمد رمضان انسانه طيبه
عفويه نسيني انها مشكله مع السرقه يعني
كده السرقه يعني ورغم سلسله المواقف
الكوميديه اللي بتجمعها بضرايرها لكنها في
نفس الوقت بتخوض رحله مع زوجها للبحث عن
ابنها اللي انخطف من وقت ولادته وكانت
بتظنوا ميت
واللي بيفتح تويتر راح يحس كانه فتح السنه
او فتح تويتر السنه الماضيه زي ما بيقولوا
يعني المنصه مليانه ارشادات وتعليقات
عالمي وموهبتها وتالقها
كمان جزء اساسي من مسلسل اللعبه اللي حقق
نجاح جماهيري كبير جدا باجزائه الثلاثه
الاولى والان بنعرض على ام بي سي مصر
الجزء الرابع اللي كان عنوانه دوري
الابطال كانت الناس بتنتظره ومتحمسه له
لكن التصوير في توقف اكثر من مره واخيرا
اعلنوا انه ما راح يلحق فيه الموسم
الرمضاني
ما شاء الله يعني مسلسلين اذاعيين كمان
بتشارك فيهم مي هذا الرمضان مسلسل سمير
وزكيه والمنظمه السريه مع احمد امين
ومجموعه نجوم اخرين ومسلسل باهي ترندات مع
سامح حسين تنضم الينا من القاهره النجمه
ميكساب اهلا فيكي معانا يا مي كل عام وانت
بالف خير اهلا يا ساره وانت طيبه وكل
مشاهدين قناه العربيه وتفاعلكم طيبين يا
حبيبه قلبي انت السنه يعني منوره منوره
منوره انا قلت لك الكلام ده تحت الهوا بس
لازم اقوله على الهواء قدام الناس انت
منوره انت مبدعه انت ضحكتينا انت بكيتينا
دورك رائع رائع رائع يا مي يعني كيف قصه
هذا الدور
اولا شكرا على كلامك انت عارفه انت
بالنسبه لي ايه بجد انا بقولها برضو تاني
قدام المشاهدين ولما بتكلميني بحس بجد كان
في شهاده كبيره حصلت والله لو انت مذيعه
كبيره ومثقفه وصاحبه اراء ومواقف وانا
بحترمك جدا شكرا يا عمري
ميرسي
الورق ده استاذ محمد سامي وهو بيكتب دور
ثريا كلمني وقال لي انا بكتب ورق همم
لمحمد رمضان السنه دي وفي دور وانا بكتبه
مش لاقي اي حد في الدنيا ممكن يعمله غيرك
فانا بكتبه عشان انت اللي تعمليه
فلما اخلص الورق الورق ده جالي انا قريت
ال 30 حلقه في نفس اليوم من كتر الفضول
وكنت متفقه معاه قلبا وقالبا ان فعلا
الدور ده اتخلق لي يعني الثريا دي اتخلقت
والحمد لله دخلت التصوير بالروح دي
والبث
وجثه موضوع السرقه يا ها يعني ههه مش
معقوله ايدك يعني بتشيل على طول يعني وبتح
تركتي كل المسلسل ايش الوضع معاك على نفسك
لحسن اسرع حاجه
ان شاء الله وهتنورينا كمان انت اصلا صحبه
مع محمد رمضان اصلا
اه جدا انا ومحمد اصحاب من 13 سنه يعني
واول مره نشتغل مع بعض وبصراحه اتفاجئت
جدا جدا بيه في اللوكيشن متعاون وبيحب
زمايله جدا وبيحب كل اللي حواليه يبقوا
كويسين وانا بشوف ان دي دائما مميزات
بتكون في النجم الكبير الواثق من موهبته
فانا سعيده جدا جدا بالتعاون معاه وعايزه
ارجع لموضوع السرقه ان انا استاذ محمد
سامي اتفقنا من الاول ان هي مريضه بالسرقه
ولازم نعمله بشكل الناس ما تنفرش منه يعني
الناس تتعاطف معاها وتضحك فحتى انا افتكر
يوم الشط بتاع الراديو ده
هو قال لي لو رجعتي عملتي الشوت ده ما
ضحكتنيش هتبقي فشلوله فقلت فقلت له ماشي
فقعدت بقى اللي هو يا رب يضحكوا فعملت
الرياكشن بتاع ان انا رجعت لورا كده ولقيت
الراديو فاحنا يعني كنا متفقين من الاول
ان احنا لازم نعمل خط السرقه ده مرضي
كوميدي
صراحه الرهيب في الدور هذا انك بتضحكينا
وبتبكينا في نفس الوقت يعني عندك لحظات
قمه في الدراما انت مش ميل شخصيه
الكوميديه ابدا انت قاصده هذا الشيء انت
عندك توجه انه مثلا خلص في السنين القادمه
يمكن تركزي اكثر في الادوار اللي هي مثلا
الدراميه اكثر اللي هي ممكن او شيء زي كذا
انا انا دايما بصراحه يعني انا مطلعه
شويتين انا بحب دايما الادوار المزيج اللي
فيها ده وده لان الجمهور بتاعنا العربي ما
بيحبش طول الوقت يبقى متنكد وبرضو هنضحك
طول الوقت فهاحس ان انا ما طلعتش جزء من
موهبتي للجمهور فانا بصراحه من ساعه سرايا
عابدين ومن قبلها كنت اشتغلت مسلسل مع
استاذ محمد فاضل واستاذ جمال عبد الحميد
هو اللي هم هم لفتوا انتباهي
اضافات لاستاذ عمرو عرفه طبعا ان انا عندي
الشقين دول انا لازم اخد بالي دائما في
اختياراتي ان انا اختار الدور اللي اعرف
اعمل فيه ده وده ولما جيت مع محمد ثاني
بصراحه يعني قال عني شهاده انا يعني حطاها
كده وسامه على صدري لما قالها قال ان انا
من مدرسه الاستاذ العظيم نجيب الريحاني
ودي كانت في هدف كبيره جدا على قلبي
ومسؤوليه كبيره قوي انك تعرفي تعملي
المزيج بين التراجدي والكوميدي فانا باذن
الله هو ده ده الخط باذن الله انا همشي
عليه وهعمله لنفسي باذن الله لو ربنا
قدرني لا صراحه يعني اصلا بتسويه يعني
بشكل سهل ممتنع يعني بتنتقلي بالاثنين ما
بنحس انك بتمثل
اروع شيء في هذا الموضوع بس خليني كمان
اقول لك بعض الاشياء اللي الناس بيتكلموا
كمان عليها على السوشيال ميديا خصوصا كتير
ناس بقارنوا بين المسلسل وبين الحج متولي
مسلسل طبعا الراحل الله يرحمه نور الشريف
كيف بتردي على هذا الموضوع هل بتحسي فيه
تشابه
خالص لان احنا الخط الاساسي عندنا مش في
صراع الزوجات على جعفر احنا الخط كل كل
واحده فينا عندها حكايتها وعندها الصراعها
الدرامي
والحدوته الاساسيه بتاعت المسلسل كله هو
فين ابن جعفر
فعشان كده انا دايما لما الناس بتقول لي
ان انتم شبه بقى الحاج متولي وكده وانت
بقى هتبقي ماجده ذكي وما هي الحاجات بقى
اللي الناس بتقولها لي دي بقعد اقول لهم
والله صدقوني ما لناش اي علاقه خالص بالحج
متولي لان ده مش الخط الدرامي اصلا بتاعنا
يعني شكرا يا مي انت رديتي على كل
الانتقادات يعني كده في ضربه واحده شفتيهم
ورا بعض ههه رديتي طب انا عندي فضول صراحه
انت جالسه في السياره كما هو واضح وجالسه
يعني ما بتسوقي واضح مش في مكان القياده
مين بيسوق فيكي
اخو جوزي الصغير اه اوكي طيب تحياتنا
شبهه صح كل الناس قلت له شبهتني يا عمر هو
شبهه قوي
لانه بيشبهه احنا شفناه تحت الهوا فكنا
امبارح في بنك الطعام فطار بنك الطعام
المصري فلقيت الناس داخله النهارده شفتها
انا واوكا فقلت لها الله يخرب بيتك شبهتني
انت مش
ايوه
شبه منه طب خلينا نرجع كمان يمكن للاعمال
انت لازلتي مهتمه بموضوع الراديو
اه جدا انا لو مجاليش مسلسل اذاعي بتضايق
جدا يعني بحس ان انا مش موجوده لان
التمثيل في الاذاعه متعه كبيره وانا
متشرفه السنه دي بوجودي على الاذاعه
المصريه في شبكه البرنامج العام طول السنه
بعمل مسلسل للكاتبه اماني درغام انتاج
وزاره الشباب والرياضه
مع شباب مسابقه ابداع تحت رعايه رئاسه
الجمهوريه
ووزاره الشباب والرياضه فانا مبسوطه جدا
جدا جدا بالتجربه دي لان طول السنه بمثل
انا وسامح حسين مع الكباب دول
فالتمثيل في الاذاعه لونه تانيه كده برضه
لانك مؤثرك الوحيد هو صوتك فازاي هتوصلي
بصوتك كل المشاعر اللي انت عايزه تقوليها
فده برده زي ترينين كده حلو يعني كمان
واحده من الاشياء اللي معروفه عنك يعني
انك انت شخصيه يعني جدعه يعني وبتدافع عن
زملائك وبتاخذي مواقف وانا حبيت جدا انك
انت اخذتي موقف ودفعتي عن منى زكي لانه
تعرضت لهجوم بس من بوستر المسلسل لسه ما
نزل المسلسل ليه بتحسي بيصير هذا الشيء
انه هجوم من اسم مسلسل من بوستر عمل
اليمين ايش بيكون الموضوع
يعني احيانا بيبقى يعني احيانا بيبقى له
اتجاهين الاتجاه الاولاني اللي هو السهل
بتاع ان انا ببقى متسرع في الحكم على على
اللي انا شايفه من قبل ما اعرف ايه اللي
هيحصل فهو ده حصل فعلا ان الناس
تسرعت ودي بتهين المحجبه المحجبه وحشه كده
هي يا جماعه احنا انا انا يعني عندي وجهه
نظري احنا كلنا خدام للدراما فانا بعمل
شخصيه يعني انا النهارده في المشهد الاخير
في الحلقه الميكب باز واتبهدل وبتاع وساح
واسود فانا انا هل انا قصدت ان انا اطلع
المحجبه وحشه بقى في الموقف ده لا في موقف
درامي انا مرتبطه بيه لازم اعبر عنه بشكلي
لان مش هقدر ده احنا كنا زمان الجمهور
بيتريق على الممثلات اللي بيبقوا صاحيين
من النوم شعرهم معمول وحطيتهم ميك اب
وبيستحمل فدلوقتي الست واقعيه جدا دي
واحده عندها حدوته كبيره قوي فطبيعي يبقى
شكلها كده ما عندهاش وقت بقى لا تحط ميك
اب ولا حتى سوري يعني تعمل حواجبها هي منى
زكي دي من المدرسه الواقعيه المفرطه فهي
بتتوحد مع الشخصيه فانا متاكده مثلا ان
منى زكي من ساعه ما ابتدت تصور المسلسل ده
لعمل الضوافرها ولا عملت حواجبها ولا
اهتمت خالص بنفسها من كتر مصداقيتها مع
الدور يا استاذه يعني طبعا طبعا استاذه
كبيره قوي فانا لقيت الناس فجاه هجوم
وهجوم وهجوم وانا الصراحه يعني انا من
معجبينها ومن تلاميذها كمان فاتضايقت قوي
عشانها لانها بجد ما تستاهلش كل الهجوم ده
ايا كان مع احترامي لراي كل البني ادمين
في اي مواقف هم حرين فيها ما بحجرش على
ارائهم بس انا بشوف انك انتقد برحمه برحمه
وبادب واحنا اولادكم يعني انا بشوف ان
الجمهور ده احنا لولاه ولا حاجه احنا
بنشتغل عشان بنشتغل عشان نساعدهم لو عملت
حاجه ضايقتك او قلت كلمه مش قصدي يعني
اعتبرني اعتبر اعتبرني بنتك وجهني
بالطريقه مهذبه هتحط لها لكن هاجمتني
بالشكل ده عمري ما هسمعه هيكون جارح صح
احنا بنبغاك تفضلي معانا يا مي هنروح فاصل
وهنرجع ونكمل معك عندنا لك كده شيء صغير
يمكن مفاجاه صغيره خليك معانا
احمد داش نجم مصري شاب صاعد للقمه وبخطوات
ثابته ومن بعد مجموعه اعمال ناجحه من
مسلسل من بطولته السنه الماضيه واعمال
اخرى كثيره كندورو فيها اساسي بيشارك احمد
في الموسم الرمضاني للعام بعملين الاول
مسلسل جعفر العمده اللي ماخذ اصداء واسعه
وارشادات وبيقوم في بدور سيف الشاب اللي
اساس نفسه بنفسه وبيكافح من عمره عشر
سنوات ولكن ما يعرف مين ابوه وكل ما يحاول
يعرف السر هذا امه ما بتقول له الحقيقه
المسلسل الثاني اللي بيقوم احمد داش
ببطوله في رمضان هو مسلسل الصندوق اللي
راح ينعرض في النصف الثاني من شهر رمضان
وهو من 15 حلقه وبتدور احداثه عند ثلاثه
اصدقاء بيوصلهم صندوق في ادله من جرائم
سابقه وبيبداوا رحله البحث الخاصه لحل
خيوط الجريمه او الجرائم والوصول لهويه
مرسل الصندوق الغامض
[موسيقى]
كل شيء بداخل الصندوق له معنى وليس عشوائي
اذا استطعت تفسير محتوياته فبامكانك ان
تنقذ روحين مين
في الصندوق هي اللي هتجاوب على الاسئله
اللي انت بتسالها
في حاجه زي كده نروح في داهيه
ما تسالش اسئله اجابتها على الدرك
احنا ماشيين بندور
ده اكل عيش
وينضم الينا من القاهره النجم احمد داش
اهلا يا احمد كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا اهلا يا ساره كل سنه وانت طيبه
ورمضان كريم علينا وعليك يا رب انا بس
حابه عندي احد حابب يسلم عليك معنا النجمه
مي كساب هي انتم ما جمعتكم الى الان اي
مشاهد في المسلسل ولكن هي موجوده معانا مي
اذا حابه تقولي لاحمد شي او حابين انتم
الاثنين تكشفوا لنا اي سر
لا يمكن
ضميرنا المهني ابدا طيب بس هتلاقوا في
المسلسل لاحقا كيف كان الشغل معك الله
اعلم الله اعلم الله اعلم طيب خلاص برافو
عليك يا ههه مي لانه التوقعات شغاله على
السوشيال ميديا على هذا الموضوع
دق جمهور الجمهور قاتلني من كومنتاته بجد
بيضحكوني بموت بيضحك واحمد انت اكيد جايتك
نفس التعليقات بتسالك على الموضوع
اه اكيد وهو وهو
محمد سامي نفسه هو كان قاصد اللي بيحصل
دلوقتي ده هو كان نفسه ان هو يحصل وهو
محضر له يعني الاسئله اللي بتتسال دلوقتي
هو كان قاصد ان يخلي الناس تسالها فده
حاجه لذيذه انك تشوف المكان المخرج نفسه
يحصل بيحصل دي حاجه جميله يعني
عشان تعرفي ان انت غاليه في مفاجاه في
حلقه بكره اهو حلو اهو خبر عشان خاطرك
طيب احنا ما شفنا بنشكرك واذا محمد سامي
زعل منك خليه يكلمنا نحن نعتذر منه
وبقول لاحمد داش الف مبروك على الصندوق
ومبروك على جعفر العمده وهو عارف انا بحبه
قد ايه وممثل شاطر وموهبه كبيره قوي قوي
مبروك علينا مبروك علينا طبعا يعني ما
يكسبوا ولا انبسطت جدا في الشغل معاها
كانت حلوه المسلسل كله بقينا
طيب احمد انت هتفضل معنا ما حابين نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا حبيبتي وبالتوفيق دايما في كل
اعمالك واشوفك رمضان الجاي ان شاء الله
وانت منجمه اكثر واكثر كانت معناها ما
يتكسر شكرا لك شكرا احمد خلينا نرجع الان
لشخصيتك في المسلسل او سيف تحديدا خلينا
نتكلم اول شيء انه يعني في تكرار للتعاون
مع محمد سامي المخرج طبعا مخرج العمل
فيبدو انكم منسجمين كما هو واضح يعني
التعاون الثالث
وهو الحمد لله اه في يعني انا بفهمه وهو
بيفهمني بشكل كبير
والحمد لله يعني يا رب دائما نعمل الحاجات
الكويسه وتعجب الجمهور وتسليهم وتوصل
لاكبر عدد يوصل
شفتها انك انت قلت انك انت هذه الشخصيه
فيها شبه منك تحديدا كيف فيها بالنكشبه
اكتر حاجتين كنت اشتغلت عليهم شبه بعض اهو
الشغل من سن صغير
انا وسيف اشتغلنا في نفس الوقت تقريبا انا
اشتغلت وانا عندي تسع سنين
وسيف المفروض بدا يشتغل بنفسه من وهو عنده
عشر سنين
فدي حاجه اشتغلت عليها والحاجات التانيه
كانت
الكرامه يعني عندنا في مصر بنقول الكرامه
ناقحه عليه شويه ما يقبلش ان هو اي حد يقل
منه ولو
بحركه صغيره حتى يتحمل على طول ويغلي كده
زي مشهد
اه بالظبط بالظبط زي المشهد دهوت يعني
كرامته لقى عليه جدا جدا طيب احمد يعني
بما انا يعني هو باين انه يعني السيف
بيتحمس في المواقف دي وفعلا كرامته بتنقح
عليه هل ممكن مثلا انت في موقف في الحياه
مثلا تضرب احد او تصرخ في احد عشان شيء زي
كده
لا بس بغلي يعني مش مش هضرب ومش مشعل في
الموضوع يعني بس باغلي
بتضايق قوي لما حد يدوس لي على طرف ان شاء
الله
بتضايق
فاهماني لا بفهمك بفهمك جدا لانه انا من
النوع اللي بيغلي برده
في احد مين دخل عليك الشيخ دي هادي سوزي
القطه بتاعتي وكريم اخويا
احمد الان انت مو بس عندك هذا المسلسل انت
كمان كان عندك التجربه السنه الماضيه كانت
15 حلقه
ونجحت جدا كانت او نجح جدا المسلسل وقتها
ايوه اهلا وسهلا سوزي
خلينا الله
سلمي يا سوزي طيب سوزي كتكوته سوزي وحلوه
يعني اربع شهور
الوحيده اللي عندك ولا يبدو عندك مجموعه
لا الوحيد واحده بس طب وشك انشكح يا احمد
لما شفت سوزي
[ضحك]
انفرجت السريرك طيب يلا خلينا نتكلم معاك
عن الصندوق كنت بقول لك انه 15 حلقه السنه
الماضيه كان عندك تجربه نفس الشيء عجبتك
الفكره حقت 15 حلقه
والله حلوه
ودسمه ويعني الشغل فيها بيبقى
مروق اكتر
واقدر اقول مريح اكتر لان هي بتبقى عدد
حلقات اقل في
بنقدر ناخد وقتنا في الكتابه بشكل اكبر لو
هندخل في نفس الوقت من الموسم الرمضاني
وبتبقى الحاجات يعني بحد كبير اروى وده
شفناه برضو احنا السنه اللي فاتت كان اظن
احنا كنا مين قال 15 حلقه وما كانش فيه
اكتر من ثلاث اربع مسلسلات تانيه 15 حلقه
السنه دي في اكتر من ست مسلسلات 15 حلقه
والنجوم كبار عاملين 15 العرض في النص
الثاني من رمضان بيظلم المسلسل اكثر او
انه يعني دي بتاعه ربنا بقى مش بقى يعني
احنا السنه اللي فاتت مين قالت اتعرض
الجزء الاول ونجح بشكل كبير الحمد لله
وكان الجزء الثاني فيه برده مسلسل بتلو
الروح بتاع
الحاجات دي بتاعه ربنا يعني سواء حتى كان
اصلا بره رمضان يعني مش مش بتاعتي مش
بتاعه حد وكمان الدور في الصندوق هيكون
مختلف يعني شيء عاملينه زي سيستم الستايل
اللي هو الاجنبي يعني القصص الاجنبيه
البوليسيه
هو المسلسل واحنا
يعني بندور على
حد
والمسلسل في
تشويق بشكل كبير حتى الصوره هتكون مبينه
ده بشكل كبير
والامكانيات في عاليه والصوره حلوه
والاخراج كويس يعني متفائل به جدا ان شاء
الله يكون مسلسل حلو وهو مسلسل شبابي بشكل
كبير ودي حاجه متحمس له دايما في
لا وان اللي بيتابع
مثلا من
الناس
في الجامعه ومن عالم مرتبه واول لا هناك
كنت مثلا عايش انه لا في الصعيد او في اي
مكان زي ما سميته احنا مش عارفين لسه او
والان انت يعني كده طالع انه ولد مو عارف
ابوه بس في نفس الوقت ناجح بس بسيط كمان
يعني بتغير كثير يعني
يعني الحمد لله طبعا انا محظوظ بالادوار
اللي بتتعرض لي وبان انا بقدر اختار
بشكل يريحني وبشكل اختار الحاجات اللي انا
احب اقدمها فالحمد لله بشوف ان ده حظ من
عند ربنا ان انا اقدر اكون عندي الفرصه
اللي انا اختار واكيد بحب اختار حاجات
مختلفه عشان انا كمان اتبسط يعني اللي انا
بعمل ده بعمل ده وبعمل
لنفسي ان انا اقدر على ده واقدر على ده
وبتبسطنا يا احمد بهذا التنوع هذه الادوار
الجميله بس كنت بدي اسالك كمان سؤال سريع
يا احمد انت عندك اهتمامات متنوعه اصلا
وعندك اهتمام بموضوع المناخ حتى والتغير
المناخي والكلام هذا كله من وين جاء هذا
الاهتمام بهذا الموضوع وشاركت حتى في قمه
المناخ اللي صارت فيه مصر كمان
انا عشان انا
[موسيقى]
بتاعتهم
اللي هي في مصر شباب بلد
اه مضبوط هي هي مبادره ما لهاش دعوه
بالمناخ هي ليها دعوه بالشباب والعمل
والشباب في مصر يشتغل ويقدر يدخل سوق
العمل بدون اي صعوبات عليهم زياده بس
المناخ دي دي مشكله عالميه
بتمثنا كلنا يعني مشكله المناخ دي مش
هتاثر عليها نكهه احمد لوحدي لا دي متاثر
على العالم كله بشكل كبير ومشكله لازم
نلتفت لها قبل ما يعني قبل ما تجيبنا كلنا
الارض فاهماني
لو ما اهتميناش بها هيموتنا يعني الطبيعه
هتكسب اي حد ده طبيعي المفروض يعني قضيه
لازم نلتفت لها بشكل كبير ايوه صحيح لازم
تاخد حقها من تسليط الضوء عليها انا سعيد
دائما ان انا بتكلم معك يا احمد يعني
دائما تسعدني
ادوار امثل موهوب ورائع فجدا شكرا لكنك
مشاركتنا اليوم وان شاء الله دائما
بالتوفيق وبالتوفيق في علاقتك قصه حبك مع
سوزي ان شاء الله يعني تكبروا سوا
السنه الجايه وهي سنه واربع شهور تكون ان
شاء الله
شكرا لك يا ساره وتشرفت بالمقابله دي
ودائما المقابله بتكون يعني والله انت
اللي وشك حلو عليا مش انا العكس وربنا
اللي فاتت يعني يا رب دايما نعملها عاده
وتكون سوزي كبرت بقى رمضان اللي جاي تيجي
معنا تتكلم
[ضحك]
عشان القاهره النجم احمد شكرا لك
مسلسل الكاسر دراما عراقيه من بطوله
الفنان العراقي غالب جواد واخراج ايمن
ناصر زيدان وبيتحدث عن صراع عشائري قائم
على الثار والتمرد المسلسل عامل ازمه
اخذ حق الناس كلها قريه قاصد وابو عقاب
راح اخليها تصير تحت حكم جاسم
خلصنا منهم يردون يقتلوني اقتلوك ما
جابتها امه اللي قلت لك وانت عمك
المسلسل ما حدد عشائر اي منطقه لكن الناس
من السياق واللبس وغيرها من تفاصيل فهمت
انه العشائر في الجنوب وطلعت الاصوات
المعترضه واللي بتهاجم قناه يو تي في
العارضه للمسلسل الانتقادات والاحتجاجات
ما حدد التفصيله معينه فيها الاساءه بس
الناس فهمت ان المقصود ظهور شيخ العشيره
في مجالس موسيقى وسهروا انه يعني مطلعينه
في صوره غير لائقه بحسب المنتقدين فوفود
شعبيه وعشائريه استفزتهم احداث المسلسل
وراحوا على هيئه الاعلام والاتصالات
وطالبوا بايقاف عرضه حتى في نواب ما كانوا
بعيدين عن استنكار المسلسل وفينا بخاطب
هيئه الاعلام والاتصالات وقال انه احداثه
بتشوه الحقائق وبتسيء للمجتمع العشائري
الجنوبي وبتمس بتقاليد العشائر الاصيله
ولا حتى بتلتزم بالضوابط الاخلاقيه للشهر
الفضيل امام الانتقادات والمطالبات
النيابيه والعشائريه وقفت نقابه الفنانين
العراقيين
وداف عنه وقالت انه هي الهيئه اللي اجازه
المسلسل بحكم تخصصها وانها مش شايفه في اي
اساءه ودعت المطالبين بايقاف المسلسل لترك
اللغه هذه ومتابعه العمل للاخر ولكن هيئه
الاعلام والاتصالات مما يبدو اقناعتها
دعوات النقابه لانها استجابه للضغوط وكان
قرارات توجيه قناه يو تي في بضروره ايقاف
مسلسل الكاسر وقالت انها بتقدر المطالبات
العشائريه وقالت انها راح تتخذ كافه
الاجراءات الكفيله بالحفاظ على مكانه
المواطن الجنوبي الكريم قناه يو تي في
وكرد على اللي صار طلعت بيان قالت فيه انه
قرار الهيئه هذا مجحف وانفعالي وفي انسياق
وراء اجندات سياسيه واستجابه لضغوط
ومزايدات سياسيه وطائفيه ومناطقيه بكل اسف
ولو انه الهيئه شكلت لجان مختصه للتعمق في
المسلسل ما كانت اخذت هذا القرار وانه
الهيئه ما قدمت اي مبرر لايقاف عرض
المسلسل وحذ ف حلقاته واكدت انها ما
بتنتمي لاي حزب او حركه وانها بتقدر اهل
الجنوب العراقي وبتحترمهم واللي بيفتح
موقع القناه مشاهدينا او قناه على يوتيوب
راح يشوف انه الحلقات لسه موجوده والحلقات
الجديده بتنزل عادي كمان
سفر برلك مرحمه او ملحمه دراميه تاريخيه
من اضخم اعمال هذا الموسم الرمضاني وهو
المسلسل المنتظر من سنوات وبدا العمل عليه
المخرج الكبير الراحل حاتم علي وكملوا بعد
وفاته المخرج الكبير الليث حجم المسلسل
بيحكي عن مرحله مهمه جدا في التاريخ اعمال
تطرقت لها ودور من اهم الادوار في العمل
هو شخصيه عبد الرحمن اللي بيلعبها الممثل
السعودي عبد الرحمن اليماني الشخصيه هي
لشاب مثقف عنده مبادئ ومعتقدات وثوابت
محدده في الحياه وبحب فتاه اسمها هند
واللي بتقوم بدورها السعوديه ميلاء
الزهراني ولكن بين جبر انه يخضع للعادات
والتقاليد وبيتزوج
هل ستغير الاحداث شخصيه عبد الرحمن
وين عبد الرحمن مدينه النور
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن اليماني اهلا فيك عبد الرحمن
وكل عام وانت بالف خير
حياك الله يا ساره وكل عام وانتم بخير
والمشاهدين بخير وكل سنه وانتم طيبين
ومبارك عليكم الشهر جميعا علينا وعليك
ويعني مبروك العمل ومبروك البطوله
بس خلينا قبل ما نتكلم عن العمل تحديدا
احنا شفنا في اللقطات يمكن اللي عرضناها
الان واللي بيتابعوا المسلسل شعرك مختلف
تماما عن اللوك اللي انت عامله الان يعني
ايش سر الوضع ايش صار يعني خليني اقول انا
اقول لك اول شيء العمل تصور تقريبا قبل
سنتين والله كتب انه ينزل الان فعده سنتين
فتغيرت تماما غير كده انا فعليا فعليا من
الناس اللي يحب شعرين فابغى اشوف اي طريقه
الام مو غير اني احلقه لانه ما شاء الله
لمن يكون واقف كانه يقشر من بعيد ههه
لقيت
خلينا نرجع
اللي هي انك صورته قبل سنتين يعني
اول شيء احكيلي اصلا كيف بدا هذا العمل
معك انا عارفه انه كمان لقصه مع الراحل
حاتم علي اذا تحكي لنا عنه
اول شيء كنت في مصر
تقريبا ايام كورونا 2020 كنت بصور عمل
وكلمني الاستاذ فراس دهني الله يعطيه
العافيه وحب اعطيله يعني احلى وامسه احلى
امسي عليه الله يسعده كلمني عن الدور
وتقابلنا انا وهو وتقابلت مع الاستاذ حاتم
علي انا اصلا استاذ فراس لما كلمني في
البدايه قال لي انا اعرف انه انت تحب
الاستاذ حاتم علي قلت له هذا صحيح قال لي
طيب هو طالبك يبغى يقابلك عشان دور في
العمل لما رحت قابلت الاستاذ حاتم علي
قبل ما تروح تقابله رده فعلك ايش كانت
انا ما صدقت يعني حرفيا ما صدقت قلت له
استاذ فراس استاذ حاتم علي يعني طلبني
بالاسم قال لي ايه انت بالاسم يعني ممكن
انا اكون من المرشحين
قلت له طيب رحت قابلت استاذ حاتم علي وانا
فعليا ماني مصدق يعني دخلت
لقيت نفسي بتكلم عفوا قلت له استاذ حاتم
انا حرفيا عندي كلمتين نفسي اقول لك هي
ممكن تعتبر ناس تعتبرها ابتداء او اي شيء
بس هي في قلبي
فراس دهني ضحك وقال لي هي كلمتين انا
حافظهم بدي اقول مثل ما هن قلت
له استاذ حاتم انا احبك وامي تحبك وابويا
يحبك وكلنا نحبك كل العالم كل العالم
العربي يحبك يعني اعمالك لا زالت موجوده
القديمه والجديده وبصمتك موجوده وتمثل لنا
جزء كبير من حياتنا يعني كبرنا على
المسلسلاتك
ابتسم معاي وجلست بعدها تكلمت انا وهو
ودردشنا كان اول لقاء بيني وبينه انا كنت
بيني وبين نفسي والله العظيم انا اشهد
بذهني لحظات واقول انا بتكلم مع الاستاذ
حاتم علي يعني
كانت لحظه للتاريخ الله يرحمه الله يرحمه
الله يرحمه الله يرحمه
بعدين ايش صار يا عبد الرحمن
تكلم معي عن الكركتر وتكلمنا عن جوانب
الشخصيه انا كنت اصلا بمثل في دور ثاني
على اساس متى ابدا اخلص عشان اجي اسمع
حضرته واتكلم معه كمان كان موجود الاستاذ
ليث حجه
الله يسعده
قابلنا وتكلمنا عن الكركتر ايوه تكلمنا عن
الكركتر فهمت منه بعد كذا اعطوني الحلقات
ورجعت قريتها بعد كذا طلبت من استاذ فراس
دهني اني ارجع قبل الاستاذ حاتم علي
والاستاذ عشان نتكلم حسب ملايات يعني كيف
شفت الكتابه ايش فهمت كذا لانه موتك كامل
كانت خمسه حلقات مبدئيا فقريتها ورجعت
طلبتها الاجتماع واجتمعنا
اديت مرئياتي للاستاذ حاتم الله يرحمه
الاستاذ ليث تكلمنا عن الشخصيه واتفقنا
على المقاطع اعطاني توجيهات واستضيف كذلك
اعطاني توجيهاته
وكانوا يعني مركزين معايا جدا انه ترى
العمل لعبد الرحمن ما هو سهل العمل ضخم
ولا
والعمل ضخم ضخم والدور مهم جدا ويبغى له
تركيز عالي يعني حتى الله يجزاك خير
الاستاذ حاتم علي واستاذ ليث والاستاذ
فراس ذهني كان لهم دور كبير في في يعني في
تذليل العقبات اللي كنت بعدي بيها كنت
مبسوط جدا بالتجربه زائدا متحمس زائدا
كبشر كان عندي نسبه خوف بسيطه انه هذه في
النهايه مسؤوليه العمل العمل ضخم زي ما
اقول لكم شايفين
بدي اسالك على هذا الموضوع عبد الرحمن
يعني العمل ضخم طبعا عامل ضجه وحوالينه
جدل والكلام هذا كله ليش تحسوا انه مهم
انه نتكلم عن هذه الحقبه من التاريخ يعني
وخصوصا في عمل درامي يعني يعتبر موضوع
ثقيل يعني
ايا كان كل شخص من حقه انه يتكلم في
التاريخ ما عاد بالك ان كان تاريخك وتاريخ
بطوله وحادثه حصلت امام العالم العربي
والاسلامي
جميع في ناس معاصرين هذا حدث تاريخي ما
عاد بالك في قصه بطوليه لك في سواء من
ابناء القبائل او سواء من سكان اهل
المدينه هي قصه كبيره حصلت عندك في تاريخك
من حقك تفتخر بها من حقك تصورها من حقك
توريها الناس
واتمنى اتمنى اتمنى من الله حقيقي انه
احنا نكون وفقنا
مبدئيا المسلسل في بدايته واتمنى انه نحن
بدانا نوري شي للجمهور يكون مناسب رغم انه
الحمد لله ربي اكرمنا انه في كثير ردات
فعل ايجابيه اللهم لك الحمد الجميع اي
والله اللهم لك الحمد الجميع مبسوط الجميع
مرتاح
فاتمنى منكم قدمنا اتمنى نوصل الحلقه
الاخيره ان شاء الله ونكون قدرنا نوصل
فعليا الاجواء حقت هذيك الايام القصه
الناس تستمتعون بالروايه كامله بالعين
ونتمنى نتمنى من الله التوفيق حقيقي لا ما
شاء الله هو فعلا عامل ردود افعال كبيره
وحتى كثير ناس يعني خلينا نقول من دول
عربيه مختلفه جالسين كمان بيتابعوه
باهتمام عبد الرحمن هذا العمل بالنسبه لك
نقله نوعيه يعني عمل كبير ضخم انتاج ضخم
بطولتك بعدها ايش ناوي تسوي
والله
سؤالك سؤالك مهم جدا الله يسعدك طيب انت
انت قلت اللي الواحد المفروض يعني فعليا
يبدا يفكر فيه دور زي هذا
في توقيت زي هذا في في قصه تاريخيه مثل
هذه تحتهم للانسان انه يكون في في يعني في
قراره شويه دقيق اتمنى انه ربي يكرمني
اقدر احافظ على هذا المستوى اللي وصلت له
وتطور الى اكثر من ذلك في النهايه هي فرصه
عظيمه جاتني الين عندي اتمنى انه ربي يكون
وفقني فيها
الاختيارات بعد كده يعني هي حتما حتكون
محدوده كل فنان انت عارفه كل فنان وله
منظوره وكل فنان له سكته وكل فنان له
طريقته يمكن لو تشوفي انا من يعني من ايام
حاره الشيخ عملتها مع مجموعه ام بي سي في
2016 الله يذكرون بالخير من 2016 تقريبا
انا عملت مسلسلات فقط مسلسل دون ومسلسل
وادي الجن بحاول قدر الامكان بشوف اللي
يناسبني بشوف اللي يناسبني في النهايه هي
خيارات والواحد بيعتبر كل اختيار تحدي
نتمنى من الله التوفيق ان شاء الله لا ان
شاء الله من نجاح لنجاح نحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله وبنقول الناس طبعا يكملوا
متابعه العمل لانه في المزيد من الدراما
كمان جايه كان معنا من جد الفنان عبد
الرحمن اليماني شكرا لك عبد الرحمن
مسلسل رساله الامام بيتناول رساله الامام
محمد بن ادريس الشافعي في اخر ست سنوات من
حياته اللي قضاها في مصر المسلسل من اكثر
الاعمال اللي كانت منتظره واللي ماخذه
متابعه واصداء من وقت ما بدا عرضه المسلسل
من امس متصدر الترند والمنصات والى جانب
المشاهد او المشاهده والمتابعه للمسلسل
المسلسل كمان عامل جدل وازمه والسبب اولا
موضوع بنسمعه دائما في اي اعمال من اعمال
السيره الذاتيه اللي هي قصه الاخطاء
التاريخيه والحقائق والتفاصيل مثلا مثل
قصه استعانه الامام بطبيب لزوجته انه كان
يلبس نظاره وانه في اخطاء في اللغه
العربيه هذا غير اخطاء تاريخيه وصفها
البعض بالكارثيه الجدل من ليل امس زاد
يشتعل بعد مشهد طلع في الامام الشافعي
اللي بيقوم بدوره الفنان خالد النبوي طلع
بيتكلم بالعاميه المصريه وهنا الانتقادات
والجدل الضعف واتساءلوا عن ظهور العاميه
فجاه وقيل انه اللهجه هذه ما كانت موجوده
هذيك الايام اصلا
موضوع ثاني مشاهدينا بخصوص المسلسل العام
الجدل وهو الاقوال والحكم اللي بيقولها
فالشافعي معروف انه من اكثر الناس
المتداول لها اقوال وحكم واشعار كل بلاغه
ودروس في الحياه وهو كمان من اكثر الناس
اللي بتنسب له اقوي الماثوره مو قايلها
اصلا واليوم مع المسلسل في ناس بدات تعلق
قلقانه انه تبدا الناس تخلط بين الكلام
اللي قالوا الشافعي حقيقه وبين الكلام
اللي هو جزء من السيناريو والحوار الدرامي
للمسلسل واللي ما له علاقه بالامام
الشافعي في الحقيقه ولكن احقاقا للحق في
ناس عاجبها المسلسل جدا وبتمدح فيه جدا
وشايفه انه في او ماخذ حتى لوحده وما
بينافس احد ومستمتعين بمتابعته لاقصى درجه
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا
اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]